TWO AND TRYING TO GET THEM
TO THEIR TARGET HERE
TONIGHT.
AYED TO THE LINE, NOT OUT.
IN FRONT FOR TAVARESST RIGHT ONS
THERE AS ROENICK DID A
PRETTY GOOD JO A PASS IN
FRONT!
JACK CAMPBELL.
[ Crowd boos ]
REBOUNDS.
WASN'T ABLE TO G
MIKHEYEV ACROSS.
BRODIE FANNED ON THAT.
ROBERTSON AFTER I
>> Craig: CYCLING DOWN.
>> Chris: MARNER CUTTING IN.LE C
WILLDS REMAINING IN
COME TO HIM AND SAY HEY, WE
HAVE SOMETHING GET HIS GAME ON T
REMAINING IN THE ROBERTSON
PENALTY.
HERE'S WALMAN. A
TOUGH ONE THERE ALMOST
HALFWAY THROUGH THIS GAME.
>> Chris: A COUPLE OF MARNER.
STAYED ON SIDE.
MARNER WOULD BUY HIMSELF
SOMETIME.
YOU GET A TURNOVER. CHANT FOR A
GREAT SAVE THERE.
AT THE OTHER END DEFENCEMEN.
COINS DENY I IT'S LILJEGREN.
MATTHEWS HAS JUST GREAT JOB
WINNING THAT BATTLE.
MATTHEWSER 19.
ONE OF THE BEST ALL
IT'S AN OUTSIDE CHANCE.
>> Chris: AND PROBABLY AN
OUTSIDE CHANCE THAT THEY'D
MO
YOU WANT SOMETHING POSITIVE.
[ Horn sounding ]
YOU ALL KNO AN BY MATTHEWS.
HERE IT IS.
SCORES!
[ Horn sounding ]
ENDS UP BEING THE HISTORIC
NUMBER 60.HING BACK IN.
ILYA MIKHEYEV SENDS IT
AROUND TO THE BY
RASMUSSEN.
NICK ROBERTSON AFTER
OFF CAMPBELL AND THE POST. RIELN
THE MIDDLE.
BACK THE OTHER
[ Whistle ]
AND NEDELJKOVIC, WHO'S HAD A
TERRIFIC NIGHT, MAX ANOTHE SIX D
KAMPF, THE NEWCOMER HAVING A
CA